how much faith do have in American
democracy um that's a hard question for
me answer I have a lot of faith in the
American system of government to me a
big part of the reason America has been
successful and stable as a free
government for 240 30 or 40 years hi
penny I account is not because of
American democracy per se or that's part
of it but because we created
constitutional Republican federal
democracy that um prevented power from
concentrating in any one place the great
danger and fear that I have is that in
the last 50 to 70 years Power has
increasingly concentrated not only in
the federal government but in the
presidency and we thought to have talked
about some gaga imperial presidency in
the United States the president has more
and more power and part of that is
because Congress has abdicated its power
because they don't want to pass the most
controversial laws or they don't want to
get in controversy at all because they
want to raise money and if you raise
money you don't want to be on record
doing this or that and so they pass
general laws and then leave the
implementation of that laws to the
executive branch to administrative
agencies the administrative agencies run
by the president the president attains
more and more power and and that is to
me the most dangerous trend in American
politics is the imperial presidency I
think we need to reinvigorate Congress
the legislative but i also think we need
to reinvigorate the states at state
government but even beyond a local
governments i think we need to bring
back the fun in politics and politics is
only fun if people think they have power
so if you organize locally and you have
no power at some point you stop
that's what scares me and so I think
what we're seeing right now on the left
and the right are disempowered American
citizens saying we want power and they
form the Tea Party and they form Occupy
Wall Street that's the good news the bad
news is as soon as they actually have to
take responsibility with the power tax
themselves govern themselves they sort
of disappear and say you know we weren't
we don't want that it takes time it
takes money it's difficult it's not easy
it's actually hard and it takes time and
no one seems to want to spend the time
on self-government anymore and so my
worry is that these movements will
become simply safety valves for anger
but not actually lead to a
reinvigoration of democracy my hope is
that they will lead to a reinvigoration
of democracy and that people will start
to become involved again in
self-government all throughout the
American system of government